Let's play!
There is a good tune!
It was the edge
And the edge of the table
I beat Miikka with a bongo!
Maybe I should start playing with this one
This is a masterpiece by me and Emil
What a beat!
It's not the fastest racket but it's
it's a nice-sounding racket!
This is the only instrument I know how to play!
This is quite fun actually!
Oh! Didn't see you there!
Such a relaxing sound.
This should be fun!
It's like ASMR
Ping Pong ASMR
Okay, this is mine and Emil's song
Like a bedtime song!
Yeah!
Do you recognize this song?
Yeah, it's the one...
It's the one called...
"Don't forget subscribe to Pongfinity"
Indeed!
Don't forget to subscribe!
Yes, that's the one.
Musical smashes
Is that an actual song?
I don't know!
New way to play guitar!
This is how every guitar player should practise!
Sorry
Amost!
Next up: a cowbell
I really like this cowbell
Wow
Okay the cowbell serve
Come on!
Drop!
Hello bell!
I like the sound
Let's try these out!
Okay I have no idea how to play this
thing
but maybe I can play with this thing
Couldn't get the short one
Miikka and Otto
The world-famous duo
Would you guys listen to mine and Otto's music?
Sounds good.
Okay let's try and lift this thing up
This thing is bigger than me!
This is so heavy!
Otto, you come and do this challenge!
So safe!
Otto is giving me forehand footwork!
Sorry, too short
Nice save
That's a good exercise
It's quite easy to play with it
But it's a bit heavy
Remember to subscribe to Pongfinity
We had so much fun filming this episode today
Big thanks to the band members of Tuure Kilpeläinen ja Kaihon Karavaani
For borrowing us these amazing instruments!
It sounds like a song actually!
Miikka even looks like he knows what he is doing!
I would give you money if you would
be on the street playing this!
Thanks!
Remember to subscribe to our channel here
And watch our previous episodes there
Until next time!